bismillah al hamdulillah Salaam alaikum
peace be with you thank you thank you
for tuning in to another episode of the
Dean show and ladies and gentlemen here
on the Dean show he is making his
appearance muhammad sharif here on the
Dean show will be right back this is the
this is the this is the thing is the
theme this is the theme
assalamo alaikum alaikum assalaam to lie
here but I can't reach be with you peace
be with you too now the million-dollar
question is what is going on we've had
everyone on the program we had sheikh
waleed Busoni we had yesterday jaws acid
is that everyone from because you're the
CEO of the maghrib and we've had our eye
on you where you been the audience wants
to know not just me you know what's
interesting actually you know I'm going
to shout out to my father-in-law every
time we do in the mother mista to class
he doesn't show up and all he does is
watch the Dean sure oh sure I said honey
la you know what I'm going to come on
the Dean show just so my father-in-law
can benefit inch thank you very much i
promise maybe sleeping thank you thank
you me this be a benefit to the whole
world as watch it because you got some
knowledge and you can't be stingy with
it so we're going to pick your brain so
we can all learn and so I can learn then
the whole world can learn who's watching
it'd be my pleasure thank you Muslim
identity Muslim is one who is chosen to
consciously submit to the one got along
without any partners equals nothing like
that and just identity in general people
are looking for someone something to
identify with and when you're not
identifying with the right people the
right thing you're identifying with the
wrong thing so let's talk about this
sure sure okay so human beings I think
in order for human beings to like
cultivate life on Earth they have this
sheep they call it cheap mentality and
people kind of make it into a negative
but it actually it brings unity amongst
people it's like you can find common
people you get together with them now
this hurting that happens with human
beings what we're talking about identity
if somebody doesn't consciously come
along and guide them in the right
direction then you know the word I would
say is like shape on or the devil the
evil one basically becomes you know the
herder of of these people and their and
their thoughts and their minds so
leaders need to come along guided people
who pull people in the right direction
for a moment tell us now you said shade
down on the devil is this real is this
something from Hollywood Bollywood
there's really satanic forces that are
working talked about this briefly before
we move forward is their satanic force I
think you know there's obviously when
you have good you just take it to the
other spectrum you have you have bad
right you have heat take it away you
have cold for those people just want to
understand that concept that it might be
like you know have you have extreme good
and then use that good starts getting
pulled away pulled away until it becomes
bad so I mean that obviously we know in
Islam about shape on and it's in the
history of all the scriptures so our
agenda here she is to help people to
understand the true purpose of life why
they're here who their Creator is and
we're inviting them to what's good ok
and now before we can even get to that a
lot of times there's confusion out there
because people will confuse like Who am
I so again they're mimicking mocking the
rappers the hip-hop stars actors and
actresses so how can we get them away
from mocking people who will only lead
them to destruction and considering
mocking the best of people which were
the prophets and the last and final
messenger is the best example please
talk to us ok sure so if you look at say
a school that has a dress code yes and I
remember once reading a cartoon or and
in this cartoon it was a bunch of kids
from another school they didn't have a
dress code and they were saying haha
look at those foolish kids there they
have you know a specific uniform but the
cartoon was making fun of the kids that
were saying this because they all have
their hats on backwards they all had
their genes even backwards and their
shirts and all of that stuff in other
words that everybody is basically
copying right and that's human nature
that we're going to copy now when you
say who becomes our role model basically
the role model is defined by the
television just by the camera so the
people they get that stage are the
actors and actresses they're the
musicians and so on and so forth so you
look at our children and our generation
it's like a whole
nation of people are being raised up
that this is the role model now back in
the olden days if you take out
television out of the picture then who
are the role models those are people who
are actively involved in the community
people who are you know doing good
things in the community that's the
person that they see everywhere you
don't see actors and actresses
everywhere you see that the leaders in
the community hence say when I was
growing up somebody was a role model for
me were like the older youth the older
boys in the community who were doing
activities in the local masjid and i was
able to you know absorb from that but if
i was to go to a Muslim kid today and
say who's your role model you know it's
going to be Wolverine is going to be
spider-man it's going to be something
like that yeah now now tell us why is it
do you feel again that when we mentioned
like let's say Moses okay peace be upon
him Abraham peace be upon Jesus Christ
peace be upon him peace be upon him a
prophet muhammad peace be upon him and
we see we we have so much utterance and
respect for them but now it's not cool
like to bring them up this is weird but
to talk about you know Brad Pitt kanno
Reeves JLo we can have a conversation
sure if you talk about these great men
and the legacy they left behind I got
time for that mm-hmm what do you think
this is well I guess that that's coming
from from a culture that is trying to
pull away from those things right so
obviously here comes these religions
they come along and and in everybody is
saying you know I'm the one falling the
true somebody says no not them follow me
follow me so that the names that are
being thrown out are the names that
you've mentioned yeah people are just
like throwing them out but so the person
is listening to that they just don't
want to hear it anymore and so their
solution is to like shut down so what I
would say is that no that's not the
solution the solution not to put your
head in the sand and shut everything out
the solution is to will search out what
is the truth there's a lot of chatter
out there there's a lot of hits and
noise but somebody needs to basically
say well what was the unifying message
of these prophets and really you know go
to a higher ground and look at
that and you will see that they're all
unified that there's no god but Allah
how can we get people to two because
obviously if you're you're hungry you're
going to eat okay but now if you're not
hungry your bellies full no matter how
great that gourmet dishes dessert is
you're not really interested right okay
so how can we get people to really to
consider this this proposition proposal
to take this matter seriously because
the lights will go on the party will end
sure and you can only acquire so much
wealth how do we get them because
sharing is caring we love our brothers
in humanity and we want them to be our
brother's a few notes what's interesting
about your question is like this person
their stomach is full even if it's a
gourmet feel as soon as you said that
I'm thinking to myself that I actually I
disagree that their stomach is full talk
to their stomach is empty empty and if
anything it's the heart that's empty
right so Allah put something in the
heart of everybody it's like a GPS so
even the person who wants to deny God
will not deny God they'll say I believe
in a higher being because they can shut
off their brain they can shut off their
heart Allah is you know like it's he's
beckoning them to come to him so this
person is actually starving but they're
saying that they're full so they go into
drugs they go into you know into
fornication they go into all these
different areas but they're still empty
on the inside so when we want to come
along and this is even from Muslims
trying to pass on the message rather
than coming to this person you know head
on and say hey follow the prophets I say
we address the problem from an angle of
you know what's the purpose of your life
let's shut off this pain and let's test
something out so for example somebody
who there was a rapper like really
intense rapper and he became Muslim
later and he was doing alcohol and drugs
and you know and the whole deal and then
there was a Muslim who invited him to
pray yeah and he said once his head went
on the ground the sweetness of his
forehead touching that carpet and he's
like you know I'm hooked and that's what
I'm talking about they're starving and
they're actually trying to fill
themselves but it's not getting the job
done it's like eating cotton candy
konkani let's take a break and we right
back with more here on the Dean show the
matter of fact you get testimonies from
Christians in Eastern Europe thanking
God for the rule of Muslims when the
Ottoman Empire came I'm occupied because
now they can have tolerance and
religious freedom i declare from today
there is nano with it'll be worship
except allah alone the one guy the one
guy because the muslim they do not like
you know force you to compare to the
religion of muhammad is the last
messenger of allah that's the same in
Aramaic jesus said Aloha so it's the
same guy same
back here on the Dean show talking about
ariat serious issues you've mentioned
the purpose of life many people they
know the purpose of their job they know
the purpose of many other things but now
the purpose of life the crucial question
people aren't reflecting are asking this
question why do you think this is okay
you know um obviously they're not asking
the question they might be asking the
question but they might be shutting an
office you know so it's like the purpose
of life I don't know so let me just move
on right but when it comes to the topic
of the purpose of life I think everybody
like we're here for a reason you can
actually you know what I was watching
iron man recently uh-huh and iron man he
gets out of he gets out of the caves and
he said if I'm still alive then there
must be a reason yeah and I said that
that's an interesting point and even you
know it was it was emotional for me i'm
watching iron man I'm emotional because
if I'm still alive here then there's a
reason for me to be here right and
anybody who's watching for you for
anybody it's like when did you think
that you had no purpose right and who
convinced you of that and who led you in
that direction so you have a purpose and
if you can accept that there even a pen
as simple as a pen if it has no purpose
once the ink dries up you throw it away
it's worthless now are you worthless and
you'd say no I'm not worthless I'm a
human being so then the the value comes
from purpose right so what is the
purpose what why are you here on earth
and hamdullah like questions like that
where other people get confused in Islam
we don't get confused we actually know
exactly what our purpose is and then
that's where the peace comes from is
knowing what our purpose is now for are
not yet Muslim audience you said to
arabic words sure so they don't think
we're saying some code words here you
said oh hum did a lot you said Islam
okay please define those please okay so
Islam is the religion of Islam literally
mean it comes from a root called salima
which means peace and Islam is like a
way of life a way of like peaceful life
that's Islam to worship Allah alone and
allah meaning God alone and to follow
the message of Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him and the second word
alhamdulillah which is thankfulness
right so alhamdulillah literally means
thank you God I was actually reading a
bumper sticker it's an it's a habit that
Muslims do in the afternoon in the
mornings to thank God very specifically
i was reading a bumper sticker as i was
doing this muslim habit of thanking God
saying alhamdulillah the bumper sticker
said have you thanked God today I'm like
I'm doing it right now we're doing it
all the time that's right is there a lot
okay we mentioned purpose of light now
where does someone who's confused they
see all these religions okay and they
say you know what it's all the same I'm
just going to do my own thing how do we
get them to think outside the box and
how do we get them to think serious and
how do they differentiate what's the
true way of life the way of life God
wants that person who live from all the
different man-made religions okay sure
so people are confused with the
different religions and we've all gone
through this stage even when I was
younger I said you know what it's not
about Islam it's not about this I'm
going to find the religion of truth and
I actually came to the conclusion that i
found it right so this is what this
would be my recommendation in the muddle
and in the in the quicksand and mud of
everybody disagreeing and yapping and so
on i recommend the person to step above
that okay now you've got higher
principles that unify multiple people
now usually people who have reached the
higher principle stage they kind of like
reject religion at that point they're
like i'm just going to take the higher
principles but i'm saying take the
higher principles and you'll find that
those higher principles are found in
islam right so for example if people are
saying oh worship this idol worship you
know this worship that and you'd say
well i just want to worship god boom you
came in a higher level instead of
rejecting the religions that's what the
message of islam is worship one God
alone one God one God that's it and
nothing that's the basis of everything
in a stamp the other thing is realize
that God created you so inside of you I
was saying earlier about a GPS your body
can sense when some you know there's
some you know funny stuff going on and
the body doesn't you know it doesn't
accept that so when you actually go to
the Islamic laws your body is naturally
inclined
into that so very often you'll hear
Islam and then you like that makes sense
you hear something else about it's not
that makes sense that makes it and
you're like the whole religions like
that is there anything just to assuage
any fears in Islam do you have like
rolling around with rats you know beat
yourself over the head with a knife or
whip and you know because people you
know they might think these things
that's just weird it is to us but we got
to say about that is there anything like
that in Islam I mean obviously the
actually the cool thing about Islam is
that there's a set criteria of how to
check whether something like that is
authentic or not a falsification sir a
falsification test in Islam and a lot of
times you know when you have with other
religions you know some person of
authority tells you something and just
kind of like okay I gotta accept it
because he's a person of authority in
Islam you don't really have that
authority figure you've got Authority
tests okay so if somebody says something
to me he's like how mad I had a dream
last night that you know this is the way
to go to paradise I'd be like whatever
right I'm like let's put it through the
filters yeah and I actually studied that
in detail automatically as soon as
somebody starts talking I'm like boom
boom oh here are the filters where did
you get this from so if you're going to
make something up like you made it up
then you're going to need to have proof
right and if you're going to UM if
you're going to quote somebody else
you're going to say so-and-so said this
right then you're going to need to bring
up the citation where did that come from
so with those two rules what's your
proof or where's your citation then
you've got like that's one of the basic
filters right there so in Islam we have
the truth and is backed up with proof of
course and we're not doing it's not
blind faith for sure there's there's no
such thing as blind faith in its not so
before we submit ourselves did we
actually know even on the point of the
blind faith yeah i would say that even
the scholars of the past they would say
that it's not even permissible for
somebody to accept my opinion unless
they know the proof right so the whole
concept of blind faith or even
protecting the future followers saying
that like you have to know the proof so
here's the proof and a lot of sometimes
people they just drop the proof though I
will just take whatever you say but
they're saying like no you have to know
the proof because the authorities coming
from the proof it's not coming from the
so it's not where you start digging in
Islam things start getting confusing
they're just it's a mystery man justjust
believe now is that that's not how does
it happen totally not that's amazing
seriousness of taking this topic serious
def can we just that is what helped me
get my act together okay was reflecting
about deaf is this a serious matter you
know ultimately you know on the topic of
death and a lot of people try to avoid
in and so on you want to live your life
prepared to die yeah right so in other
words you know recently in my city there
was an earthquake when an earthquake
strikes that's not the time to start
thinking about death you know like every
day you wake up in the morning you want
to say to yourself am I prepared to die
today am i prepared to die today and
that's got to be like in your mind all
that's like your life mission is
preparing to die so that when the time
of death does come along it's like
you've been preparing for this your
whole life alright and that's what life
is all about it's not about oh let's
live in the moment it's like let's live
in the moment with our hearts in the
hereafter so that we make the right
decisions in the moment now living life
according to God's will not your desires
paradise is that guaranteed for an
individual then if you do all the good
that God wants you to do and you die in
a good righteous state worshiping only
the one God following his last and final
messenger which obviously proceeds all
the other messengers the glad tidings is
this what we're seeking paradise it is
it is but I would also add something to
what you said is that human beings they
make mistakes yes right so we're not
saying what other people of other
religions have said that you know what
as long as you accept this and that
you're going to go to paradise we know
as human beings Islam is a natural way
and a person will make mistakes yeah so
it's not a just a utopia or ideal or
perfect person so in Islam the Prophet
peace be upon him said a prophet
muhammad peace be upon him said that
every son of Adam every human being
makes mistakes right so when I make a
mistake as I've made you know today like
hundreds of mistakes just in this day
I'm thinking myself I'm a human being
I'm not an angel and that's what islam
teaches me I actually tell you this this
story I was at a Tony Robbins convention
yes right and I was sitting beside a
Jewish man
and and I was listening what Tony
Robbins was saying I was getting excited
just a big tall guy big tall guy he's
kind of tall like you and and then I was
so happy I'm like I can I can implement
what this guy's saying and my Jewish
friend was saying to me that you know he
was feeling sad I said why he sad he
said because what Tony saying is um he's
like I know that one week from now I'm
not going to be able to keep up with
that and I said you know what that's the
beauty of islam because i'm not worried
about keeping up with it because i know
that as a human being I'm going to dip
and when the dip happens I just turn him
back around right so in Islam when a
person makes a mistake they ask Allah
for forgiveness and Allah one of God's
one of his name's is the oft-forgiving
and he loves to hear our forgiveness so
I'm like I'm a human being i made a
mistake today hola please forgive me for
this and I know that by me asking
forgiveness I'm actually coming closer
to God God Almighty is the most loving
the most merciful the forgiving will
leave on that note for a second we'll be
right back from more on the D show is
born about 60 years ago in former
Yugoslavia today's Bosnia at the Second
World War and imagine today you have one
child feel so much it's important that
we realize that Islam is a gift so we
believe that in the teachings of Jesus
what is left there is truth in mean he
is the priests but the truth has been
mixed up with paganism and with nature
worship and so Islam is given you a pure
straightforward way of approaching
monotheism
grrrrrr
back here with my brother your brother
Shaikh Mohammed a shitty that shitty and
we were really I'm thankful that you are
here with us Thank You Ramon since our
leisure being here thank you and sha la
we can have you back again sometime so
now we're talking about we started out
talking about identity okay so we define
somewhat just gave people somewhat of a
taste of what Islam is about okay so if
you push towards identifying more with
Islam the Creator is way of life that
he's given to us to live by what are
more of the positive outcomes that
you'll have as opposed to identifying
again with the TV stars with the rap
stars etc okay perfect okay so Allah or
God has he created human beings he knows
like the master plan of where we're all
going and what brings what will bring us
prosperity and what will not so for
example something like alcohol as a
Muslim I don't drink alcohol so the
people that are caught up and they're
addicted in and it's causing all the
harms I'm already protected from that
because Allah protected when it comes to
you know the mortgage crisis in the US
as a Muslim I'm not involved in taking
or receiving interest so because of that
I don't have a house I didn't get
involved so when the market collapses
I'm already saved from it because I was
never there in the first place right and
so the only one who's saving me from all
of this is Allah Almighty and is because
I've taken those promises God's message
and implemented in my life and I've been
saved from these harms maybe in the
short term if somebody was to say hey
just have a glass of wine it seems like
oh I'm missing out or so on and so forth
but look at the long long term effects
of those things and you realize that
Islam has protected the believers and
sometimes I'm like with my wife and i'll
say you know what we really need to be
thankful for this religion of islam
because of how many vices we've been
protected from because of islam big-time
big-time and we think the creator of the
heavens and earth for guiding us to the
truth and protecting us
and tell us now for the Muslim that is a
little nervous about his identity so
you'll say and you'll be happy to see
the person and you want to give him the
salami assalaam alaikum is I hey how you
doing or you say you know Muhammad is
that you know is that it's actually mo
what advice do you have for them ok so a
one person that I have this um this
criteria I tell a person that you know
if you're going to a park to pray and
you feel nervous whose permission do you
need if they gave you permission you
would feel comfortable praying so I'm
like what is it the government that you
want to give you permission to pray is
it you know like a non-muslim walking by
you want them to give you permission to
pray who if they gave you permission you
would be fine and then when they if you
identify who that person is because even
in the example that you gave they've got
a co-worker that they've actually made
like their slave master right and they
become a slave to them it's like ah well
I can tell you what my real name is
because slave master so and so and and
that person doesn't even know they were
made this late it's like arbitrary
they've put people in their lives above
you know themselves and I would say so
when I'm going to pray and I start to
feel nervous I say to myself I don't
need anybody's permission to pray and
nobody is my slave master I'm a free man
right land of the free home of the brave
and that's what it is Muslims need to be
you don't need anybody's permission to
pray to Allah son of them now we want to
talk to our sisters we love so much and
they also have an identity the the
Muslim identity but some of the Muslim
sisters they're a little more scared of
what the environment the people might
say so they Lear away from wearing the
proper identity to a job what advice do
you have for them ok it's the same
concept as well it's um we're saying
earlier about kind of like the Sheep
mentality we want to identify with a
group of people when you're living in an
area in a community that's not
worshiping Allah you actually have to go
against the that sheep reaction and
you've got to say you know what I'm a
leader I'm not a sheep here so what this
sister you know that's this you know the
pull of the sheep the pull of the crowd
or is she gonna
away on identify herself so she really
does have a big test but here is the
beautiful thing for our Muslim sisters
is that because in an early age they're
like dressing differently they have to
become stronger at such an early age so
their identity in fact if you take a
Muslim man and a Muslim woman a Muslim
woman who's like wearing hijab she's
usually much stronger than the man
because her identity has been you know
brought up all these years and that
interestingly is that protection they
always speak about a job as a protection
a lot of people don't realize that your
identity is being protected and your
character and your strength is being
protected because you're not becoming a
sheep when you wear that closing
comments and suggestions for those who
are having identity crisis if you have
an identity crisis I say invoke the
Sheep okay and by that I mean that you
will have a shipment a sheep reaction so
get with good companionship go to your
local masjid find some good people and
and say basically like i want i want you
to be my shepherd right and i want to be
in this companionship so if you with a
group of three four people that don't
swear and you say a swear word they're
kind of shy away from that you'll feel
bad and you'll start changing your
vocabulary with a group like that and
that would be my suggestion get in some
good companionship in the last 30
seconds talk to us talk to them about
your Institute that you're the CEO of El
Mago demand how people can get involved
taking some classes to get more
knowledge about Islam okay sure so a
member of institute we do on to weekend
seminars right now it's one of the
biggest projects islamic projects in
north america and in the UK you can get
more information at ma crib gorg that's
al ma GH r ib org and we do cities in
about we do classes about 30 cities
across the Western world so there should
be a city a class happening near to you
we started with peace we unrepeated on
alaikum alaikum assalaam may god
almighty allah reward you thank you
thank you very much and that was my
brother in your brother shaikh mohammed
el Sharif here on the Dean show giving
us some great advice establish your
identity in
crater the heavens and earth has told
you what your identity needs to be you
need to be a Muslim one who has chosen
consciously not by coercion but has made
a rational decision that I want to do
God's will I want to do all the good
that the crater of the heavens and the
earth has told me to do and then the
reward is paradise Jenna so do this good
beseech him ask him pray to Him repent
to him alone without any partners co
equals no one nothing is like God and
pray to that one God and the going gets
tough or whenever you're in distress he
is the only one that can answer that
call your prayers and we'll see you next
time continue to tune in every week to
the Dean show until then peace be unto
you he created the universe to him
belong the heavens and live l11 he is
the first he's the anomaly eat them his
messengers to all his creatures
on the grave danger Oh worshipping a god
than Allah there is none greater there
is none greater you have to pray as if
everything depends on the market it does
but you must work everything depends on
you and it does that's my point you see
the same and I don't like that I don't
like us sitting here what are you
waiting for what are you waiting for
right now what are you waiting for all
these people to come to this long what
are you waiting for what are we waiting
for right now when they're gonna come
they're gonna come along and bring these
people lost upon the water put in our
hand the ability to do it now do your
job
Oh
I am not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone if a box by my
side I am not afraid to stand alone I am
not afraid to stand alone if a lot about
this I i am not afraid to stand alone i
am not afraid to stand alone if Eliza I
am Not Afraid